[Music]
[Music]
I'm Sarah does my husband Dustin we're
here in Pacifica California just 30
minutes south of San Francisco and we're
originally from Florida but moved out
here about 2 and 1/2 years ago we met
yeah we met at a wedding yeah and I gave
this speech at the rehearsal dinner the
night before and it moved Sarah to tears
and she came up to me and talked to me
and we had a special moment and that
that was the beginning
we met at our best friend's wedding best
friend's party I think it was definitely
a god thing because we were in Tennessee
when we met at the wedding and then we
both lived in Orlando Florida at the
time I was dating someone at the time it
did it and it wasn't gonna work out so a
couple months later Dustin was very
persistent and trying to get a hold of
me and so we went out and the rest is
history
in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Dustin
and Sarah are with us welcome guys how
are ya hi Dave were great doing a great
day of things before we got married we
went to 13 weeks of premarital classes
and there was one week that was finances
Sarah had mentioned that she knew some
friends that went through FPU and I was
really familiar with Dave Ramsey because
I used to listen to him on the radio
with my dad and we knew first of all
that we wanted to combine our finances
everything was gonna be equal equal say
and everything and that our you know
family household was gonna be one bank
account we quickly joined bank accounts
finances we both had student loans both
had credit cards a little bit from the
wedding but mostly preexisting a car
payment I mean everything that's pretty
much normal and the far as normal
Americans and
what their finances look like we wrote
down all of our debts on a piece of
paper
we had a journal it said this is how
much debt we had and we listed it out
and we had a goal to get 10 free by
October 2017 so we would technically buy
this math that we created we would still
be in debt and then honestly like two or
three months later every dollar came out
and then that changed our course yeah I
think the biggest impact to use every
dollar was you saw the category you saw
what your budget was you were familiar
with the amount so as you spend you were
highly aware of what was gonna be taken
out just cuz it's so easy cuz I mean we
both had it on our phone and you'd see a
transaction and one of us could put it
in the category and it was just kind of
it was really easy to share the the the
duty of the budget and one time I saw a
charge and I said hey did you make this
charge and we actually found out we had
card fraud from the every dollar app so
really what you're saying is is the
budget and working together where your
two big things that cause you to break
through
I would say the first you know real
turning point and our journey was we
would get home from work look on social
media and we'd see people that graduated
the same time as us from school and
they're going on a cruise or a vacation
somewhere
buying a new car buying a house and we
would look at each other and just say
how are they doing this they graduate at
the same time as us they have the same
type jobs and I knew if we wanted to do
those things that we were gonna have to
seriously make some some changes so that
was kind of always going in the back of
my mind
and then Sarah gets this opportunity to
advance her career in San Francisco we
start looking for rents in the area and
it was that was a huge eye-opener and I
was like there's there's no way we can
afford to live there and then we started
doing the math it's like well if we cut
out this and if we make this our grocery
budget I think we can make it happen and
then I said okay like if we're really
gonna take this leap of faith to take
that position we really have to get
serious we have to stick to this plan
and that was like the final okay do this
so we can live there in the moment now
and then we knew even after a few years
it might be possible to get debt-free
then we could start going and doing
vacations and doing trips and just
really do the long-term goals that we
talked about while we were either
preparing to get married that's where I
think our debt-free process started as
soon as we move to California
live in a cool place so you sit down and
do a budget you get on every dollar
right and you get an attack mode so what
was the hardest part of the last 22
months this isn't a 50/50 thing this is
a hundred percent 100% of everybody
because when the other person needs help
you've got to step in and fill in the
gaps then so through the whole process
of getting out of debt I would
definitely say it's really positively
affected our marriage we knew okay we
can't spend money to find entertainment
so what are we gonna do we started
hiking around here and started taking
advantage of Northern California and
being here and say okay we're on a very
tight budget maybe we add a little bit
to gas so we could go to these national
parks and we started making that the fun
part of our marriage and we had this
goal to climb Half Dome in Yosemite
National Park and in September 2016 so I
a month before we got out of debt we got
tickets because you have to play the
lottery and we were able to climb it was
18 miles 10 hours we were hardly in any
sleep because we had to work the day
before and after right we actually slept
in the car I saved money too it was so
freeing like the last I don't know if
you're familiar with the mountain but
the last quarter mile of it you're 90
degrees above against the rock and
you're climbing like this holding on to
cables unattached those cables at the
end was like the last push it was like
our debt free journey like the last
couple of months we were able to just
push it through and we were throwing
2000 2500 I think one month we've
through that $3,000 at the debt I was
like wow I can't believe when we are
free what we're gonna be able to do with
this money
how's it feel now you don't have any
payments feel rich yeah it's like a huge
weight off your shoulders we did their
first monthly budget and then we had all
this money left over and of course
that's going to emergency fund and our
savings but it's like wow you know this
is something that we can use to finish
and complete some of our future goals
and travel and do the things that we
really want to do and we're passionate
about
it just felt like we were on top of the
world it's kind of the same thing when
we did our debt free scream it's like we
were able to accomplish these goals we
set for ourselves that never even could
have dreamt was a possibility all right
it's Justin and Sarah San Francisco
$50,000 paid off in 22 months making 95
to 150 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream okay three
[Music]
[Applause]
eyes
you have to rely on each other you have
to go into an area maybe you've never
gone before outside your comfort zone
you have to make these sacrifices that
in our world in our society we're not
used to making these sacrifices what you
do now the sacrifice you make it's gonna
pay off in the long run and I know Dave
always say live like no one else so one
day you can live and give like no one
else and just to see that in our lives
now to have that the sacrifice has been
made and we're able to to give to others
and help others out it's tough yeah but
after a few months some of the
sacrifices we made to our budget
truthfully we didn't even notice I just
encourage anybody grab every courage you
have and go for it don't look back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]